that's not the plan
I was going to say for you like uh you
know because because the bending record
what came out last year right the last
hour
um what's it like getting on a you know
kind of getting one of the elite MCs in
this [__] to to bless because that's the
record George was on too right yeah yeah
what was that process like you guys are
both obviously I guess well he's on Def
Jam now but you know label Made issues
in fact yeah I mean the Common Thread is
definitely Nema like he's he's [__]
damn near Steve Nash at this point bro
like definitely a Steve Nash type of guy
yeah he's crazy like
um I linked up with Benny and we had
just followed each other on Instagram
and we have spoke
um both East Coast [__] so I feel like
the the Synergy was already there
um but once Nema got involved in and
just made it happen it was pretty easy
he did it real quick he killed it you're
pretty big on a lot of the Griselda [__]
all of it yeah yeah Conway is probably
my favorite there Benny Conway is my
favorite I know everybody I mean I love
all those guys but Conway's [__] [__]
rap his ass off bro and he like makes
you feel like you're like damn I want to
produce for him um that's that's
probably the main person what do you
produce on
Logic Pro X logic yeah so you've been
doing that for a minute because I feel
like anybody who does [__] on logic like
that's what they learned on and that's
just what they're on like I can't move I
started in 2015 and I looked at Ableton
and that [__] looked like [__]
airplane yeah Ableton Ableton like I
feel like when you look at Ableton it
looks very intimidating right yeah it
just doesn't make sense the interface to
me like you know
yeah exactly it doesn't make sense to me
at all yeah like logic makes sense facts
yeah Pro Tools makes sense even even
Fruit Loops you'll look at it and you'll
be like oh I see what they did there
yeah
you'll see Pro Tools or you'll see Fruit
Loops and you'll be like I see it I get
it no but Ableton is the one where
you're the cycle this [__] looks like
[__] yeah it doesn't make sense
trigonometry bro yeah you know what I
mean like physics
I feel like if I learned how to use it I
would be such and then I don't
understand the touch thing like there's
like the big thing they sell and it's
just got 800 buttons what do I do with
this no yeah it's not practical no and
I'd be seeing like shout out to the
people on Tick Tock shooting fake
producer videos your [__] NPC ain't
hooked up you're full of [__] you're
just pressing buttons the Beats already
been made yeah you know what I'm talking
about oh yeah and then there's the DJs
who like there's nothing plugged in like
what are we doing here like bro I ain't
gonna lie I've done that a couple times
with the Beats I did a DJ set where the
whole [__] was done in logic already uh
you just press play just press play and
I was up there on my Denzel [__] it goes
but you know what that's at least I
respect that because you at least put
the set together yeah oh the transitions
was crazy and a lot of um a lot of the
bigger EDM DJs that's what they do but
they do it in Ableton oh yeah yeah yeah
I've watched like I won't say their
names but like in Vegas I've watched
like some of the biggest
DJs in the world just their computers in
Ableton session yeah and they just press
play I mean they're moving with knobs
yeah hey
look
yeah uh you guys got any tour stuff on
the way yep we start in September doing
us and Europe Canada are you guys
excited to go out
yeah sure that's where we Thrive for
sure so is it just YouTube you guys
bring a full full band yeah I feel like
the full band is definitely like
especially it's got to be the key man
because I feel like when I first saw the
roots I was 12. wow and I was like this
is the craziest show I've ever seen like
a hip-hop band like you know I mean
obviously there's been more incarnations
of that since I was 12. but at the time
when I was 12. It was kind of crazy to
see right yeah so I love to see the
younger like kids feel that for the
first time when we dropped black vintage
a lot of those kids [__] with it a lot
it was reminiscent of outcasts and
Kendrick so they came to the show but
they hadn't they have been going to
other shows so they hadn't seen like of
Us come out and they're doing full
orchestrated you know run through the
whole show so I was gonna say for the
type of music you guys are making I feel
like there's definitely like a huge Lane
now as to where maybe when you first
started or even like three or four or
five years ago it was kind of like an
underground Niche Lane as to where now
like guys like the soul action radio
guys have kind of there's like this Lane
of just like great soulful music that is
finally kind of coming to the Forefront
you know what I mean we're still trying
to find our tribe too bro like it's
difficult with this kind of music
because it's not applicable to like the
quick [__] like Tick Tock is it's not
gonna work there
oh man like it's it's not necessarily
like prone to go viral it's definitely
something that people have to you know
ingest that's why the live show is
important right exactly but then the
question is like how do you get more
people to to get to the live show so
we're still trying to find our tribe I
mean our fan base has grown tremendously
you know on a global level in the last
the the two years that black odysses
existed to the world but um we're still
trying to like crack that code you feel